everyone this is Steve Allen trouble
with Collider calm and I am here with
director Chad sterile ski or John wick
three how are you doing sir good thanks
for having me I'm super thankful that
you are here especially in the middle of
your press tour and I'm what you guys
probably can't see on camera is a
crowded theater before we get started I
want to give a huge thank you to
Lionsgate for being an awesome partner
and letting a screen the movie early I
want to give a huge thank you a huge
thank you to everyone at IMAX because
IMAX is easily the best way to watch a
movie
the format's incredible you can see John
wick three for one week in IMAX starting
Friday let's start immediately with IMAX
uh you any feelings I love MX only way
to go right IMAX but I mean in all
seriousness it's it's an incredible
format and if you've never seen it
before this is the movie to start on and
you can see behind us the screen is
massive jumping into why I get to talk
to you first
congratulations on the movie movie is I
don't want to curse but it's a fan
incredible well effing thank you so
jumping backwards you finish John wick -
at what point did the studio say to you
the movie comes out opening weekend it
does well at what point does Lionsgate
call you and say hey uh are you thinking
about a third I think it was probably
yeah maybe two days Monday Tuesday maybe
by Wednesday we got all say would you be
interested in thinking about number
three and you know and I said sure give
us a couple weeks to think we took a
couple of weeks and we thought about it
and we said we're gonna need a couple
more weeks
we just want to make sure that we could
come up with an idea and had some
thoughts that were gonna be worthy of
the time and the commitment and all your
fan
Thank You nests and then yeah I think
you know I we really love the world we
love the character I love working with
you and yeah we went back to Lansky and
said yeah I think we have a few ideas
and we'd like to give it a go and then
we started development so at that point
you have you thinking okay I'm gonna do
the third movie the you guys designed
such incredible action set pieces at one
point in the development process is it
like that day the early thinking about
how are we gonna top ourselves and how
you know what I mean like how does that
come together um I don't think we've
ever really had the thought of how do we
top ourselves we certainly don't try to
go bigger or better we just try to do
that's like all you guys you have a good
day you know you want to have another
good day I don't know if you wanna have
a bigger day but you might have a better
day so you know we have a big notebook
we have a big office with all these
ideas on the wall and some things made
it the first time like some things maybe
the second John way and some things end
up in the notebook a lot of it is an
open development like we like to joke
that we're we're incredibly backasswards
in the job world we don't write the
script first we have our vision board
the big ball with all these great
pictures and photos of actors and casts
we love or references or latin phrases
or locations you know pictures just of a
horse good idea
I love architecture I love music so
you'll have a you know you'll have a
picture of or something reminds you of
Beethoven or Ivaldi or Haydn and then
you'll see something of you know I have
this big pair of ojio art I love
Renaissance art sculptures anything
that'll spark something and then we
start crafting we had a big picture of a
desert going Wieck suit desert great
weight story then Keano guy and start
working with characters and threads you
know I told Gianna like look I'd love to
have this ninja guy in there zero he's
the zero of everything that's great I'm
gonna have something called an
adjudicator I mean it's great I looked
at word up and it was like okay judge
we're gonna judge this and then you know
we need someone that's gonna be the
moral rather than just have a specter
like bad guy association that's gonna
deal with the financials we're gonna
have a moral guide to the underworld
we're gonna call him the elder but he's
not gonna be old and okay write all that
down and then I'll write a 50 60 page
story almost in bookworm and then we
start branching out the writers let me
start actually developing the script but
to your point for all the ideas it kind
of comes that way a lot of it is as
we're writing I'll go and start scouting
a city like in number two was Rome or
New York and literally I was walking
through Central Park it was almost
Christmas time it was freezing out and I
was walking in my production designer
Gavin Kavanagh
and we're like Jesus it's freezing out
here like where they put the horse so we
asked the guy that did one of the
carriages like no right over there I'm
like over where he's like by right
across Fifth Avenue this is stable and
you're looking this is not the
brownstone look like new and sure enough
you walk in this four levels of horses
and we just started smiling going oh
don't wait coming in here and then you
know you take that and okay John wick
runs into stables in Manhattan okay Nona
believed that that'll be fun great okay
and then I recalled this incident where
you know as a stunt performer way back
when I got kicked by a horse and it
wasn't as bad as what you guys just saw
but like it hurt
my horse okay good um I wrote that and
then and I was like I love westerns you
love westerns I love Western you know
Sergio Leone thing that we're all fans
of he's like John wet suit ride a horse
right ride a horse I got one better ride
a horse your bro good so we start
designing stuff that way and then you
know like the knife fight you guys saw
it's a culmination of who here has ever
thrown a knife a degree okay did it ever
stay
me neither hit me right ahead - so
with our company our choreography teen
the 8711 guys and stuff we try to
subvert all the time doing every action
move you ever seen Hiro picked up a
knife he throws it what happens dead nut
sticks right on you were like yeah
that's never happened us so what do you
say John wit just misses a lot and I
grew up with my brothers in
Massachusetts and we had a snowball
fight again you know I was always one
and then they were too he takes many no
balls as you can you get you just start
talking and see win by four so we
thought we'd have a missing snowball
fight with knives right snowball fight
with knives and that was the the brief
to the stunt team you know we just gonna
come up with ideas like that you know
ride horse but not well got it
ride motorcycles with swords got so in
the in the pre-production process you're
coming up with these ideas talk a little
bit about how long it takes to actually
implement these things because I want to
give credit 8711 you know your company
does incredible work and does incredible
work for so many different movies but so
say you're gonna be filming and let's
arbitrarily say June when are you
breaking down the set piece in terms of
designing it and putting it together um
you know if you're talking about the
martial art side of things or Agra fee
we start pretty early on depending on
the classic and we'll start almost
six-month they'll I mean it's not like
you don't jump in and do eight hours a
day it's like everybody here you got to
get in shape to get in shape nobody here
couldn't survive a two hour straight
workout you start with a half-hour
workout shape now I'll work another pass
is no difference to break them in slowly
they don't get injured
everybody gets but he pulls a muscle
everybody gets tired yeah
break him in a little far out and then
you know there's the new skill set make
anybody here you know to get him to do
the splits might take a little bit
longer than how to do judo so you kind
of work your way in like that it's the
other stuff he gets a little trickier um
luckily we you know we have a honor
who's been in the action world for a
long time he owns his own motorcycle
company he's been on horses his whole
career he's fired weapons he's done
martial art though Burger fees a lot
tougher than you think it's not learning
martial arts learning the dance learn
with the you know more like dance in any
real martial art because you have to
remember the choreography
learn skill but again he's good at that
it was probably the animal so what we
wanted to do with the dogs located about
that well actually I want to get into
the dogs but I want to actually do get
something before we get to your dogs so
Halle Berry is incredible in this when
did you realize that she would be able
to do everything she does in this movie
spoil it without I don't wanna do
spoilers but she kicks a lot of ass and
so talk a little bit about that and then
let's get into the dog um we haven't it
was right after the incident so Joe's
right after Christmas and we just
started working on Laurie in the grip
and we knew we wanted a really strong
owner
you know we had always seen like we're
like this is for the role and that had
gone out over the wires like look this
is gonna be a heavily physical role you
know who out there who has clients that
may be interested in the huge commitment
it's gonna be a six-month commitment not
gonna be able to take another job so and
that's tricky like in Hollywood is
people to realize most chimes on a movie
yet what we rehearse right you know the
bigger the name asks the less time you
have because they're booked on these
other dub when you start training for
something like a maple movie or a big
superhero movie like that's the massive
mint that means you can't take any more
money you can't take another job you
can't go to your kids basketball game
you're gonna live
Oh to find somebody like that tricky
that wants to commit and then I got a
call from WME saying
Ali Barry would like me
when today okay
and her down um literally Holly was at
my door couple hours later and I had
never met her and how he came in and
said look I'm a big fan of the first two
John would like be in your movie I'm
like that's I'm flattered that's amazing
just you know we haven't read the script
yet she's like no no no I I don't care
I'm like yeah well I think your agents
would probably care you know like
there's no script I don't even know the
character's name is Jeff she's like
that's okay we can figure that out I
really gonna be in your movie and and I
was trying to be you know then what bull
but again Halle Berry hard to say no
like I was really flattered and you know
she looked amazing she's an incredible
shape like I'm gonna be in your movie
and I'm like well okay she's like no I'm
serious you don't understand I tried to
give her an outgoing like look I'll get
back to when we have the script but work
around it will start writing the part
she's like yeah yeah that's all great
but I'm going to be in your movie
like it's gonna be six months a trench
that great when we start I'm like no
like you don't understand the die it's
gonna be fun for a week and it's just
gonna suck like the diet the three times
there's three different workouts you
have to do you have to do this dogs for
anything yeah the martial arts you go to
firearm training and yeah it's done
teams like yeah I got it I'm like
everybody says that but no one gets it
and like yeah she never missed a day so
I don't know she hired me or I hired her
but that's kind of like that I got to
tell you the level what she does on
screen is very impressive and nowlet's
without getting into any spoilers in the
trailers and images you've seen she has
dogs he does and so um I don't want to
say exactly what happens on screen but
she what she did to have those dogs
perform the way they did on screen is
crazy and I don't think a lot of people
know what she did and you could sort of
talk about that um I guess again
if people don't know when you an animal
any type of animal that you see on
screen they don't know it's a movie
you guys get there's no such thing as a
movie dog or a movie they've been
trained to do certain things in a movie
environment but they're animals they
don't come out of their trailers they
don't you know they're just
so when you see a dog - a dog attack on
screen in a film that's actually a dog
trying to injure a human being they
don't know what play they're actually
attack human and then either the Train
of the stunt person who's in Kevlar gear
or body armor and they're trying to
survive um that wasn't gonna work for us
you know we figured that it wasn't gonna
do well um those of you that haven't
been on a set before it's a pretty
chaotic place there's background going
around you know at any given time with
30 40 stuntmen we have multiple animals
on set firearms a lots going on cameras
running everywhere and most of the time
we see like a dog attack on screen it's
what is it wider shot or a type shot
it's one person be attacked by one dog
so we just said how can we make this the
most impossibly hard thing and we could
do so we tried to do it the way you've
just witnessed on screen but what it
would have to take is after we talk to
Andrew Simpson he's a guy that does all
the wolves on Game of Thrones probably
in my mind the best animal trainer in
Hollywood anywhere in the world right
now um he's just like the dog whisperer
but we said look I don't want to do that
I don't want to do real tracks is there
a way you start from scratch and train
these animals to actually be part of the
Sun actually teach him jujitsu moves and
all this stuff and have him acclimated
he's like oh yeah absolutely no
absolutely take a year of your life and
you'll find special dogs and you'd have
to have a stunt team and a cast that was
willing to work with him for five to six
months and I went
[Music]
and that's it and we spent all our money
train dogs for a year so Andrew went
around the United States found five
Belgian Malinois a Belgian Shepherd from
different military installations that
had not yet begun their training and he
found him with the physical and mental
and personality attitude that we were
looking for and we got five and it
started literally three weeks later
where the dogs were trained with the
trainer's first and we brought in the
first dozen stuntmen to train with them
all the dogs know you by smell or acme
though when the dogs are release
everyone says they love dogs until
there's a hundred and ten pound animal
crying then you have some reserves and
the dogs wreck that so we found the
stuntmen that had the the best mental
aptitude towards animals that were angry
and the dogs and then became very very
close friends and after that we had to
acclimate the dogs to the cameraman and
says if firearms to all the noise and
sound that we're going off and then
because we wider and we try to do a lot
of intricate long takes just like we do
with the the martial art stuff the dogs
needed to stay in the shop
which if you don't know they can't have
leashes on them or the trainer can't be
right off camera the what rather than
have painters in green suits we just had
Hallie be the trainer Ellie not only to
be friends with dog take the dogs home
deliver the dogs to feed the dog the
cuddle and play with the dogs but to
actually training amantha month pet so
when you see her on screen giving the
Arabic words of man she's actually
so that little
I don't want to obviously get into the
specifics at the film but I think in the
trailers you've seen it's part of the
Morocco set piece and I think we would
all agree you all just saw the movie
without spoilers that set-piece is
jaw-dropping it's crazy what you do and
there's always two dogs doing stuff I I
don't know if I've ever seen a movie do
what you did yeah no yeah yeah well we
kind of call it porn sorry there's
martial arts porn gun porn sword porn
which is our little way of that was like
our our we wanted anyone to know that's
work with animals before like yeah we
didn't cheat this like there's two dogs
on we wanted to come back and kind of
show you that they're not goofing around
and it wasn't a digital dog it was all
all real dog
it was a lot of time and effort put in
but like I don't know there's something
impressive to me about Ashley seeing
performances like that that's why Keanu
does as much of the action is can white
why we over train our cast to be you
know part stunt performer as well and we
and we wanted the same work and the same
kind of credibility out of the animals
in the films uh I want to talk a little
about the editing process when you're
putting together let's arbitrarily say
the Morocco sequence with Halle and
Keanu fighting talk a little about how
much is that all figured out on set in
terms of how you're gonna be cutting it
how much is it working with your editor
because some of the editing I mean it's
it's all about the editing to put
something like that together again
I'm a big fan of live performances live
dance or old musicals or you know
exhibitions anything like that and
that's why I shoot the way I do it's not
really a [ __ ] you back to anyone going
like we don't use shaky cam we don't use
I'm nothing again shaky can't have
nothing against tighter shots or fast
editing it's just that's not what we
were tried to do I'm John wick so rather
than how most people do it will teach
the cast come in the camera and see it
on the day they try to capture as much
they can for the time they have and then
the editor figures it out way back in
prep with the rehearsals I'll have my
cameraman come to rehearsals three or
four months out so they're acclimated I
have my cinematographer come there so he
knows where to put the the wider you
shoot you limit your other departments
if you're not telling your
cinematographer that you're gonna shoot
wide into this long dolly shot he's
gotta know where to put his lights so
now he's scrambling to try and make that
work and then the cameraman you just
asked the stuntmen to rehearse two
months but the cameramen rehearsed for
an hour
my most films and that's why you get
that kinetic sense because they're just
they're missing they're trying to find
it and the Wardrobe guy he hasn't period
cuz he hadn't seen us he's only got one
suit so you can't script that suit and
that's how it all starts to go to [ __ ]
so we're like okay that's happened too
much we're gonna treat this like a live
show everybody's coming to the
rehearsals three months out so the
editors there he understands Evon shift
is my editor he's been my editor for
last two films we like what we call
symmetrical editing 90% of the the
scenes in John wick weather astronaut
will start very wide medium tight tight
medium wide and they'll be symmetrical
we find that interesting because it
feels like you're bringing the audience
in it's almost like a slow push like you
guys are sitting right now and you're
watching the screen here in IMAX the
screens a little bigger so it's a little
bit more what we're trying to do if it
was a more of a regular screen you could
just take it all in without panning your
head with IMAX you can sit here and you
kind of got to search the screen a
little bit to follow the action that's
kind of what I'm trying to get when we
do the editing style that we're doing
it's not so much of a massive
perspective shift like going over the
shoulder over the shoulder and
flip-flopping the ankles it's slowly
bringing you into the scenes slowly and
you come out it just makes you relax and
become more observant of what's going on
and that's kind of the editing style
that Evan and I have always tried to to
try to get with the action so it's like
you're sitting in a live theater just
watching the performance you just add
there's a guy on the stage
there's a guy on stage and look there's
something oh there's something going on
down here and that's what we talked
about quite a bit so that's the first
thing the second thing is like a lot of
times especially because I shoot on
actual locations you know there's a lot
times I have no idea like zero like we
lost three locations in Morocco we lost
in Marrakech we lost in Fez finally we
found the town that we shot in a swara
that we played for Casablanca and we got
our first location we're ready to go and
I don't know if you can tell by that but
it's a huge fishing village so when we
got there in the summer after having
scouted it well we didn't realize how
much fish it was being brought in every
day and there's over a thousand cats
when we got back there okay I don't know
if you know anything about dogs and cats
but like they're distracting to each
other so we literally had our 30 cat
Wranglers clean out the fish market and
it got so crazy that we had a move
locations to the next square over and
that changed configuration so while we
know patterns and sequences it took the
stunt team another day like we didn't
sleep for a weekend just trying to
reconfigure it so we could share our
camera angles so it's in answer your
question it's it's a set and it's as as
organized and planned out as we can make
it always having that 10% planning to be
as organic and as liquid as possible to
make make room for changes again we
don't try to teach the cast 10 moves and
hope they remember it we have a little
model the best way to fake being good is
just to be good so we try to just train
them as stunt performers and we don't
worry about just having memorized 10
moves so we want them to be able to
change and adapt on the day so you'll
hear hi Hayley still gives me quite a
bit of [ __ ] she's like we trained for
five months and then we make it up on
the day and that's not far from the
truth like she was taught all the pieces
and has this toolbox of sequences and
moves and then I might go okay take
section one put it over four four over
here five here three is not working I
very much like a dance choreographer
will change routines but the background
will know their pieces and we just move
and mix to make it feel more again it
can sometimes I do it just to liven
things up I'm curious how long was your
first cut compared to the finished film
ooh
the directors bane
four people don't live they don't
realize the first cut is where you put
everything in there and then just to see
what you have and the first cut can
sometimes be very long what's the great
quote if you don't have enough to throw
away you don't have enough so I think
our first one came in it and that was
pretty proud to get it down to two hours
and 44 minutes to 44 was I think my - 44
- 45 was my directors assembly and then
the director's cut which was so much it
was like 2 hours and 29 and a half
minutes and I was really proud of that
and is that something that like you were
the 229 cut was that something that like
you were like oh you could watch this or
was it like oh no we still have a way to
go but I you know I could watch like a
Jackie Chan video all day long you know
I mean I could I mean I still love
Lawrence of Arabia I still love the old
seventies films really you know running
time was not an issue like that was your
Sunday like I'd go with my mom and dad
to the to the movie theater and it's
like alright bring it and then you'd
watch Lawrence of Arabia like twice and
there's six hours gone so like I have a
different kind of endurance for that but
like it was definitely watchable it just
you know for you guys if for every I'll
so like you're pacing the two biggest
things the directors really got to worry
about is always tone like what Toni
writing is this funny to come you don't
confuse emotionally the audience too
much unless that's your goal and then
pacing you know like you want to give
action like you know you guys know like
you watch any action movie there's a lot
of like John wick is a great example
first one there wasn't a single piece of
action for 22 minutes like can't even
talk for 22 minutes like we knew that
going in we're gonna mess with pacing
and then it goes and yeah oh this is
weird and then it goes like we wanted to
have that jump start number two's
different we started hot and got really
slow just to lay by goes Jesus this is
born then boom okay we'll wake you back
up number three I was trying to be again
I'm somewhat of a new director so I like
messing with things and still trying you
know we wanted to keep it going you can
feel the first 20 minutes they're like
non-stop there's a ticking clock and
then it's like put on the brakes
let's talk and give you some story and
show you some of the world and then
there's when he gets back in New York
it's okay fasten your seat belts here it
goes and that's the fun part I mean I
don't think you can have a really
interesting
paced action movie without having what I
would not consider slow but definitely
you know put the brakes on for a little
bit and enjoy the film I love the
experience of sitting in a movie theater
and watching I love a live show like I
mean Hamilton had slow parts tensed up
me or anybody else wasn't seeing it I
thought it was great
every good dance performance has those
really dynamic flashy moves and then it
has this intimacy that you know suction
to the performance that's all we try to
get here I'm assuming that there was
what was the last sequence you cut out
of the movie that you know like the last
thing that almost made it into the
finished cut and why did you take it out
mm-hmm good question
the last thing we cut out there's a
scene randall duck in the dr. John wick
helps out and thanks oh well he had a
scene with the adjudicator and it was an
interesting scene because he was
punished for his his helping John wig
and why it's fun it's good it just we
had to keep intercutting back and forth
between John and the desert back to New
York and we just felt it was one
transition too many and it kind of
stopped what was already a slow slow act
so we kind of took that out to help move
things forward to get to New York a
little quicker was that sequence like
over a minute or was it something she 90
seconds it wasn't it wasn't a lot but
like you know when you're watching
something and there's a rhythm going 90
seconds can feel like 10 minutes
you must have test screen the movie I'm
curious what did you learn from those
test screenings that impacted the
finished film people's tolerance of head
shots now honestly you know you test
screen against wide demographics we did
a blind testing for people that don't
know that's they purposely screen out
people that like action movies or have
seen John with one or two so that
audience one doesn't like action movies
and had never seen John wick one or two
so interesting interesting notes some
interesting reactions of ooh wow why
which is good but you also learn things
about you know even though they weren't
action fans and it was a few hundred
people it was like you know seeing Halle
Berry in the role the world-building the
color at least you know I got a couple
well at least it was competently made so
that's good I feel good like my editing
and my my lighting was successful and
the camera wasn't too wacky
so that was good my choice of wardrobe
was okay they may not understand like
we're what we call hyper real and John
wick you know it's a little over the top
so they kind of got the theatrics and
what we're trying to do in terms of
creating a you know basically a
live-action anime or live action video
game so they got that and you also get a
real sense of what they can endure and I
mean that in terms of what we were just
talking about pacing what they're
willing to sit through when it's not one
of your interests or passions and that
really helps cuz like I got a lot out of
it actually actually I was really
against the studio for making me do it I
was kind of angry about it but at the
end I've never seen you angry I'm I'm a
pretty angry guy but I put into my work
now it you learned a lot as far as i
concerned about pacing and tempo of how
we were doing things so while I didn't
take many notes about cutting out it was
a little like 40 minutes of action they
wanted me to cut I was gonna do that
the body count is over 100 it's gonna
stay over 100 but it was good and there
was some logic questions that was nice
to test that they actually understood
having not seen the first two films so
it was educational for sure so did you
make because you did a few test
screenings and did anything else through
all the test screening process impact
the finished film or yeah no we up until
I think you guys yeah really you guys
just saw that was the first time we had
the ending we had we had a very
different ending up until literally a
month and a half ago that shot the the
final one the final scene with the
characters involved was new that I'm
trying to put my music but mine was a
much more abrupt ending if you can put
your heads around that one
it just didn't it didn't resonate well I
didn't have the impact I was hoping for
so yeah you talk about it and you try to
come up with a better way of ending the
film that was a big thing and trying to
think what else we had those that was
the main thing was just really about the
ending like we we knew we had something
fairly decent it's just okay you want to
leave the movie with everyone going okay
I'm satisfied but what's next you know
and there you know there's a million
things I could say about the ending and
why we end all these chapters like we do
and mostly because it's a chapter sure
you and Keanu obviously have a great
relationship while making the third
movie what was the biggest fight you had
and why if you had one no we don't
really fight we've known each other for
a long time we've been kicking the [ __ ]
out of each other for 20 years was there
a strong disagreement or something um
I'm just gonna interject and say there's
a glass house in this movie and I
watched I I was very lucky and I got to
do a set visit and I watched Keano do
stunts after stunt after stunt after
stunt like it's unbelievable what he's
willing to do and I'm just curious at
one point does he ever like just say
okay enough I got you know you know what
I mean
not in three films I haven't seen and no
I did three matrixes with him I helped
him out when he directed mana Taichi and
I did Constantine with him and now three
John wicks and I've never seen him not
get back up it's crazy
he's a pretty I mean he's a very
impressive man he's my favorite human to
work with on the planet
I mean I can't say enough good things
about him he's incredible
you know we'll disagree with motivations
sometimes like I don't think it was an
argument but how to do the scene in the
tent with the elder and what that was
supposed to mean and all and stuff that
was a point of big discussion and the
ending was a prior two biggest
discussions but they were all very
constructive and positive I mean he's
the most non confrontation you see him
internally but I swear he's incredibly
non confrontational he's the most
collaborative cast member I've ever
worked with I mean
you know I sit here as you know the
title says director but you know Co
collaborator and co-creator is
definitely Keanu Reeves which action set
piece in the film gave you nightmares
horses men horses they're tricky now the
horse thing was good and at the end of
the day you know I got to put my lead
actor on a horse going 35 miles an hour
down you know the elevated train of
Brooklyn and like you know we rehearse
and we do things we put safety lines on
we do a million different things but you
know [ __ ] happens sometimes you try you
know it's always nerve-racking and Keano
has like you know how the respect of
everything we do but like you know he
just doesn't know how to say no so
sometimes you have to watch that and the
horses just wouldn't I mean we were
supposed to be getting to make that
sequence work the way we wanted and we
only got half the sequence that was
planned we need to be getting 10 to 15
setups a day set up is part of the
session of the sequence and on day one I
mean we only have the elevated train in
Brooklyn it's summer which was even
dumber for me to shoot during the summer
so I have like eight hours of darkness
and I think we got one set up by 4:00
a.m. so like day two I was already a day
behind so that was pretty bad and that's
because the horses just wouldn't they
didn't want to come out of their trailer
that day it was just you know animals
have a bad day when they're done they're
done and they just weren't responding so
we had a like column down take him back
to the stables you know bring out the
second set of horses from LA and then
try it again and that's when it started
working I believe Darren Prescott was
your second Union director good Francis
I believe if I remember correctly when
you were filming the movie or getting
ready to film the movie there were a few
set pieces that you guys that he was
still trying to figure out how are we
gonna film this thing was it the horse
stuff was it the motorcycle stuff what
were the sequences that you guys were
because you've been doing this a very
long time
so for and Darren's been doing it a long
time so for you guys to be struggling
means like it's holy [ __ ] hard yeah I
mean when you write character rides
horse does this to motorcycles crash
yeah your head goes okay we'll use the
stunt doubles here we'll see Jesus face
we do a face replacement here and then
you know the the more
you know arrogating and difficult
director says no we're not gonna use a
double we're not gonna use that we're
gonna have Keanu Reeves do it that
throws a wrench into things so when I
told there and like no we're gonna do
this let's figure out a way to do it
so the first one was a horse thing how
do you get Keanu on and do it safely and
not kill your lead cast member because
they don't want to do that yeah that was
a little tricky and him and our stunt
coordinator Scott Rogers figured out a
traveling safety rig that went above
Keano and all the horses and they still
crash the motorcycles live and did all
that stuff so that was pretty impressive
that they figured out relatively quickly
like within the first two months and
then when the motorcycle sequence again
you have a lead actor that can ride a
motorcycle more than or better than most
stuntmen and then you close down the
longest suspension bridge in the United
States the Verrazano and then you got to
give all the stunt guys swords and then
you got to try not to stab each other as
you're going 65 miles an hour
little tricky little tricky we were
trying to we saw this movie a couple
years ago called the villainous and then
you guys seen the villainous makes a
great great film tangent yep his brother
was the one that got the thing in the
head
anyways when we had to do that sequence
of villainous is great movie so we
thought okay that's great and we got to
talk to the drought start the directors
know the people that made it and we're
really impressed by how they did the
digital stitch in between live-action
and and and CGI and we thought this is
great John wick as you can tell isn't
ode to a lot of the favorite action
films that did from Kurosawa to Leone to
bertolucci to Tarkovsky to you know
Jackie Chan all the way through some of
the Bruce Lee films from the second film
so we thought it'd be a good idea to
like you know we love to create Asian
films that we are from Asian cinema the
raid we loved that so you can see chap
chap in yen in there and the villainous
so we're like okay we're gonna do this
and then we started sitting down we
watched it on it's like oh that's
awesome you know what that's great but
we had no idea I did it and we tried to
break it down I'm like this really good
they did a great job so it took a little
while to figure it out and then how to
do
it a little bit more live-action than
then even they had tried and to put our
lead actor in it they did something very
cool and sneaky by putting helmets on
everybody didn't know who's who we took
the helmet off and said you're gonna see
this guy and that took a lot more
planning than we thought it was going to
take and about two months of rehearsals
between the the sound stage work and the
live-action stuff you co-directed the
first John wick and you've done the last
the John with two and three what do you
think you've learned as a director from
the first film to now the third film you
you know what I mean look before we did
that Dave and I both had a good solid 10
years of second-unit in action directing
behind us and you know you're directing
big action directing cast you know
everybody from Will Smith to Brad Pitt
siano just horse- Stallone we had done
so much work on the Expendables and some
of the superhero things and Marvel
movies you know we were pretty arrogant
or let's say confident I guess yeah we
got this we got this no problem we're
gonna start going in but the ability to
talk to cast and really hold true to
that threat of what the characters doing
when you're shooting out of order is you
know it's it's an amazing skill set that
you have to have you have to track
things that you never really had to
worry about it's just an action guy the
idea of blocking and saying something
with the camera other than just catching
a big explosion or following the car
chase is always challenging like what
are you saying you just are you moving
the camera just to move the camera are
you trying to say something we try to
capture an emotion are you trying to
bring something out in the story
we're big silent movie fans which are
amazing they brought up a lot of stuff
without editing or without a lot of
talking or exposition so we just tried
to keep that the the motif on the first
week of we're gonna show you not tell
you and that was a big thing and then we
realized about I don't know maybe three
days in that yeah we're not as good as
we thought we've cast so luckily we had
Keanu on our side that says a you're
gonna be working with whelmed Dafoe next
week you might want to get you [ __ ]
together
I don't like yes that's a really good
idea man so let's get dummies guide to
how to direct
no we got in and just you start learning
that you just don't say go again you
don't just say that was great hit your
mark like how do you really talk to him
to bring out what's on the page and
really explain what's going on do your
homework and we had a pretty good idea
about that but like we really had to
hone our skills so we kind of cracked
down and really started working with the
cast a lot more than we did it's the
same thing you know like great as you're
putting a camera so we're great at
action but like can you tell a story can
you tell the story the way you want to
tell it so it's not just forced through
editing and that was a big thing and
then in post which is a whole other
world that most actually I just don't
have to deal with it's the things that
we're just talking about is like how do
you maintain the tone of your film
because the original John wick was much
darker and much more grounded and we
wanted a funner film so how do you
maintain you know basically killing a
puppy and have fun I think that's a
trick and then you know and then with
pacing and how to keep things grounded
how to give a little motion to something
and how to make it you know kind of
paste through and move through the
action you know again this is just my
third film so I'm a bit of a new
director still constantly learning
trying to expand you know you know
accept that you know I mean there isn't
a dad and go to set and literally
thought I was gonna [ __ ] my pants I mean
what's the better way I was scared every
day like you don't know you don't fail
you don't want to make mistakes you
don't want to be caught up not knowing
how to do something because you didn't
do your homework er because you didn't
read enough because you didn't research
enough because you didn't think about it
enough
so yeah it's terrifying but you just
can't be afraid of being afraid and you
just got to try and you got to keep
experimenting and when something goes
south you get her correct it and try
again
the next day you know it's like learning
anything else I guess which I would
imagine you guys have designed a whole
bunch of set pieces between the three
films is there a set piece that came
this close to actually being in a movie
that got cut out for whatever reason oh
I've been trying to build a glass house
for three movies it just costs a lot of
money
I love optical illusions anybody that
watches magicians live or some of the
bigger guys they know you can use glass
to refract reflect and that's always
fascinated me about you can see on all
the John weeks we do gags with
reflection and I think that's the
duality of that reflections all that
stuff is fascinating to me is the
thematic
and in human nature so we try to put a
little dot and everything that's why you
see the glass house and our the the
mirror room and number two in the Glass
House and number three but I love that
idea of being able to see and not hide
anything and you don't see wires you
don't see the camera you don't see
anything it
it just feels expansive to me and it
feels retro at the same time is you know
slightly futuristic you know it's a cool
vibe when what was it like telling the
studio or your producer about the Glass
House and or the you know the glass in
this movie and were they like uh no no
there's a lot of Tears ya know they they
kind of look at you like that's great so
how much are you actually gonna build
they're like they give you the nod like
yeah that's that's really cool cool yeah
how big does it have to be and then you
start doing the numbers and they okay so
do you really need all four floors well
maybe I could do three and you always
again you always ask for more because
you know you're gonna get squeezed so I
got two floors and I started with all
right and it was much bigger when I
started but ya know they're good he's
you just you gotta fight for you want
that comes at a cost you know the
original schedule for this film was I
think it was I just had under I think I
had sixty seven days and then you start
baseball card trading he started going I
ended up shooting the whole movie
including Morocco and the additional
photography and 56 so where are those
days go well you trade the money of
those days to get bigger sets or cast
member or more camera like you know you
constantly got to deal with the the
budgetary restraints because it there
are financial limitations to what you're
making so fortunately enough I had two
great producers a unit production
manager and a line producer that were
very good at helping me manage what I
had that's how we got the glass house
one of the listen I think the one of the
things that the award season always
overlooks is stunt work and I'm just
curious what do you think it will take
to get stunts treated seriously for what
they are because they're incredible
people they make movies no III would
caveat my answer by like I love some
people I was one I came over one I think
I have one of the best on teams in the
in the industry for fight query are
and for what our guys do um I think the
industry does look it's not like the
industry or the Academy for that matter
is against some people getting an award
there's just a small difficult with it
difficulty with it meaning ok who do you
give the award to I mean the first
answer is always do you give it to the
performer that did the stunts do you
give to the choreographer that
choreograph the stunt
do you give it to the stunt coordinator
that budgeted and scheduled the stunt do
you give it to the director that came up
with the idea do you give it to the
editor that cut it I've seen great stunt
work go to [ __ ] with that editing I've
seen a great performance amazing in
person the guy cameramen didn't get it
rather they shot too tight or too loose
you know I've seen you know I've been in
the room with some great directors that
I you know I came up with which house
keys I can tell you as a fact they
design their own action so who'd you
give the award to you know something
I've never actually thought with what
you're saying right now you've given me
a different I'm oh I'm all for it a
hundred percent for it I think the
department in itself should be
recognized to the Academy absolutely I
just don't know what would be the
fairest way to do it what have you seen
in the last number of years or in your
career
so what stunts have you seen that you're
like holy F yeah there's been some good
ones
I like sequences so I don't look at a
particular stunt I look at a sequence
like what's a great card chase what's
the great fight scene what's a great you
know I I love Casino Royale I love the
opening of that I thought the the free
running of the park or where that was
you know the way they shot it and cut it
was very exciting
we keep Daniel Craig ian was great you
know one of my best friends Tim Rigby
did the base jump off the Corvette in
the first xxx I think that's probably
the best done the last 20 years
okay the beginning of this movie has
Keanu fighting a very tall gentleman Oh
bond bo bond a little bit I mean the
sequence is incredible how talked a
little bit about putting again spoiler
for you but talk a little bit about
putting this thing together because you
can't double someone who's 7-foot
whatever now I was a
couldn't figure out what I want I needed
a couple more set pieces and configure
it was so I'm a big fan of walking
around New York and I ended up in the
New York Public Library just wandering
around I was like yeah screw it let's
just shoot here and I'd like this be a
great place and then the same thing we
try to subvert so we're in this big open
space and you could put as many stunt
guys you want in I ended up wandering
through the stacks and I was like this
is great let's do it in a tight space
like this but not let's let's not do it
with a regular-sized stunt man let's
supersize and we'll find the tallest
biggest guy that could barely fit in the
librarian and that'll be the way we'll
open the film that'll be funny it'll be
great
it'll be their cream abdul-jabbar's and
Bruce Lee version a game of death like
this is gonna be great except we
couldn't find an eight-foot-tall stunt
guy and I lamented my issue to a
producer and I know absolutely zero
about the NBA I mean I'm not good with
balls like football based I don't know
anybody but he came in it's like okay
great I got what you need is Bo bond and
I was like what's a bo bond and he's
like he brought up the videos of bo bond
at the time he's playing for the the
Clippers and I was like this is great
this guy looks amazing he's great size
and you know but can he act can he do
anything and he had done some
commercials over in Europe and I was
like he's got some charisma he's got
this great thing and apparently has the
biggest hands in the NBA so from a
choreographer standpoint I'm like
perfect the hand cream dude Jabbar we
got this
so Bo bond flew from LA to New York we
gave him a two-week stunt test with the
stunt team and he was great he was great
and then we had him read Dante which was
pretty funny and no he did great he had
no problem with it and the stunt team
game thumbs up we put it in the library
and we had the talk and I'm like look I
know you're professional athlete but
you're eight feet tall there's gonna be
no stunt doubles it's gonna be a 14-hour
day are you okay he's like yep and he
was pretty good he's a sweetheart of a
guy he actually had a kick the the
stuntman that you saw in there and he
didn't want to touch him because his
shoe is a size 27 so it went from crotch
to nose so like you couldn't just put a
pad right here
and he's a little tentative and Keanu
stunt-double a guy named Jackson Speidel
who's a fantastic stuntman just like no
no just kick me and boba is kind of look
at him like have you seen my foot like
no maybe you should just in one and I'm
so good and we had like we could do this
all day but it's gonna be better if you
just kick him and that's the take that's
in the movie just once and we thought he
was gonna land there and he kind of
landed way over there even Jackson got
up and went Wow pretty good it's a great
opening to the film thanks I think I
think most people would enjoy thanks I'm
curious there's been a lot of talk at
the studio and just about expanding with
John wick universe the continental what
is the status of other stuff besides the
future films right now the they're
trying to do a TV show called the
Continental it's based on the John wick
universe with John wick the character of
passing in and out I'm currently in
development they're trying to get it all
right but they are they are working on
the scripts and the episodes and stuff
it's currently with stars which is a
Lionsgate and stars right now but from
what they've sent idea-wise to to myself
in kyon oh it sounds really really fun
they've got a really great take on it
and you know they're currently in
developing this is not about John wick
but you've talked many times about
Highlander and I'm just curious where
are you at in in the development of that
the magic word of development I love
Highlander I love the original I love
the whole thing about it you guys like
Highlander I figured we did gun so let's
try swords right no I love the love the
theme of immortality I love the idea of
love through time I love the idea of
burdens of immortality about you know
how the only people you can really trust
and bomb were the ones that want to chop
your head off I think that's awesome
it's something we've been working on now
for two years it's something I want to
continue to work on I just think it's a
very deep universe there and I think
what happened and again I'm just
assuming from the original is once you
say there can only be one and then you
get down to one and then you tried
sequels that becomes difficult so we're
trying to not to back-end ourselves into
that and create a proper story that we
can build off of I want to make sure
that people in the audience have a
chance to ask some questions I have
another thing I want to ask but if does
anyone have any questions that they want
to ask so we can probably get like six
people or so right over there
so if a few people want to go over there
and and in there we go we'll see what
happens and but real quick while they
were getting in line what TV show would
you love to guest direct Wow
there's three I've been really impressed
with like I wasn't originally a Game of
Thrones fan but I think there's a couple
in there that I was impressed by you
know if that was still going on I'd like
to take a stab at something like that
all the bastards I thought that was
incredibly well done I just I swear to
you I just watched two episodes of Cobra
Kai the second season this morning
[ __ ] genius I loved Johnny I think
it's so simple and yet so twisted in how
they did it and then I've been watching
a lot of Barry I think just in the
simplicity and the funny and the
darkness of I take I think Barry would
be my choice to answer your question the
this if you were not watching Barry Bill
hader's Barry and HBO
phenomenal and the episode that was just
on the other night was jaw-dropping yeah
big fan let's open it up to the audience
hi I'm curious about your expanded
roster of writers that you had on this
movie as opposed to the first two and
kind of how the story developed after
the brainstorm that you mentioned at the
beginning and kind of how you assembled
that team as the process continued good
question again in the first film when we
got the when Dave and I came on board
John wick was written by a guy named
Erik Kolstad he's the creator of the
John wick thing that you see his name up
there John wick was originally 65 years
old a retiree from Cold War with a 10
year old German Shepherd and he killed I
think three people in the first scripts
that changed
I think it was the idea like Derek
brought some really into the gold coins
were part of it but it was more of a
Cold War it was based more on practical
stuff like if you were a spy from the
Cold War you wouldn't have cash you'd
have gold bullion that you could trade
in any country nondenominational that
kind of thing he had hidden a gun behind
a brick fireplace he had all so there
was things and he did there was an old
hotel in it that was called the
Continental that had the concierge and
had the secret little speakeasy
underneath but it was much more grounded
and I'm a huge fan of Greek mythology
and all that and obviously you can see
the references the names he's on the
characters and that's what we wanted to
kind of hyper stylize and comic book and
an anime it out a little bit that was an
idea we all kind of gone on and Derek
jumped right on board that we started
doing all the the the Greek and Roman
god mythology study and kind of twisting
it like that and at the end there was
kind of a happy ending I guess you could
say in there in the original script then
after Keanu got involved we got involved
it all became much more twisted in odd
it's a world of bad guys my point being
is when you write a script most of your
action movies they're you know the guy's
an assassin but he's got a good heart
something happens to his wife and then
he redeems himself and we go with a
little bit more of the darker Faye
ballistic themes of not so much
redemption but fate and karma and grief
and obviously consequence you do bad
things bad things happen to you and
that's never gonna change
and that's kind of why we end the movies
like we do because there is no in our
mind riding off into the sunset
there's no it's not gonna get better you
know and he's not gonna be rewarded so
do you point different writers bring
different different things to it so
that's kind of how we got the different
writers hey I loved it thanks thank you
so much I'm really curious because you
have X amount of years you've so much
you've so many years of like experience
with choreography and doing stunt work
and all that amazing stuff and I know
you're booked for like the next
five plus years or so with all your
different projects but like I hope I
don't know yo say I don't know that
being said are there any like musicals
you have in mind that you'd like to
tackle at all whether they be like
reboots or things from Broadway or we
did the premiere in New York a couple
days ago and I sat right next to
lin-manuel yeah that is Hamilton was one
of my all-time favorites uh I didn't
know I said literally sat next to him
and he was cheering louder than anybody
else in this either so we ended up with
a great conversation afterwards and you
guys know who Bob Fosse is yes one of
the Triple Crown probably the only man
out there that's ever won the Emmy the
Oscar and the Tony in the same year I'm
a huge fan of Bob of fauci's and his
career and what he's done from all that
jazz all the way onto Pippin I I think
that's amazing anybody that comes to our
place and and five minutes talking to me
knows that I love dance choreography and
that's where I steal most of the ideas
for from our shahadat choreography
sooner or later somebody else will catch
on I'm sure right now I think we're the
only ones they trained that way the
answer to your question is yes I think
to be able to express yourself at one of
those base levels of human experience or
nature which is dance to have that and
be able to tell stories not just that
our musical or or
meant just for the sake of being a
musical but actually tell a story that
way like up on a lies Dave I think that
would be a directorial challenge that
I'd like to take I know it sounds funny
coming from the action guy and stuff but
I would love to I would absolutely love
to if the if the script was written by
someone that was trying to say something
more than just let's dance and sing yeah
yeah it seemed like it'd be great fit
Thanks hi there I just wanted to know as
far as the romantic aspects between John
and his wife and we used to see a lot
more flashbacks in the first one can you
see more of that happening towards John
wick for do you think that maybe you
know his wife could still be alive is
that even a possibility or I think she's
bringing back I think she's passed away
or what about I look at the backstory
Bridget Monahan - I think she's a
phenomenal actress but I think she's
passed but I know you're saying the
romantic interest I think again if this
was like say our good guy typical action
movie yes we'd flashback there'd be new
scenes in every movie I just don't feel
like beating the audience over the head
with that is really what we're trying to
say it's about grief and it's the chance
to experience grief I'm sure we've all
had a bad day or lost someone or lost
something that we care about and we've
all needed time to recover from that I
think you know the universe takes and
gives as it sees fit but how we react to
it is ours it's very private thing so
once you lose something and if you were
robbed of that time to grieve to express
yourself I think that would be more
frustrating than even the act of losing
and I think that's what's important here
and what John's trying to get and that's
his main motivation so rather than do a
flashback or something like that and
bring back his an image of his wife I
kind of chose to be a little bit more
symbolic and go with the ring so what
John does in the elders tent is more
symbolic of giving away the last thing
he has or the last part of John versus
that which is the ring and I think I
mean you guys got it right all right I
don't think you have to beat the
audience too much John
I was in the bathroom for that part
that's why was that little segue blu-ray
right after the desert has a peak and
hold it but what about Halle Berry's
backstory do you think I mean it seems
like she has something going on with
John wick are we gonna see more of that
or she done you know those are all good
questions I I truly do not know I like
Sophia I think it's a great character
again an overall answer to a lot of the
questions you guys may have have is as a
director you come back and you know it's
funny I learned from the witch house
keys when they're doing the second
Matrix I was really happy to come back
and do it it was something I was very
proud to be part of and they look
miserable what's up and they were like
curse of the sequel curse of the sequel
like how do you be original the second
time over and give everybody what we
love what we loved about the first
matrix how do you get that feeling that
nostalgic feeling of wow I was really
impressed
do it again and then make it different
because if you do the exact same thing
it doesn't have the same impact and
you're like well they just copied
themselves so not only do I try to do
different set pieces I try to different
storytelling devices
you know flashbacks a symbolism
symbolism flashback that kind of thing
and if you're gonna do you know any kind
of romantic lead or bring back
characters like I love common from the
second week I love my cast in the second
film you know I love John Leguizamo I
love that it's just I don't want to be
stretching and trying to use some cheap
device like you know I you don't think
there is people talking about why don't
you just kill another dog like for me
you get one puppy a career so you don't
want to keep tugging on that but also
it's the same thing I don't want to keep
tugging on this thread of why for grief
like you have to create new motivations
as you go if you can continue a
franchise and that's I wouldn't say the
struggle but the challenge if we were to
continue this universe in any way or
number three is just how do I get the
same things across you guys and make it
fresh to make it new or give you
something to think about and that's
always the I guess that's what we think
about most when we're trying to write
the story we have to get the next person
I'm not trying to be difficult
just running I'm talking in the parking
lot I'd be great uh just wondering uh do
you think John wick could have killed
Thanos better than the Avengers oh is
that a question yeah yeah and where's
there a second name of the chapter other
than Parabellum it's funny I whatever I
have a fetish with Latin I like Latin
phrase I like the etymology of our
language and how to say things with
words because I think that that's a big
thing one of your writing I try to get
out sometimes the lack of saying
something is stronger than saying
something sometimes the way you say
something of the how you say something
or the what you're trying to say comes
across in different ways and languages
our main tool for that so to understand
it I think is very important for
anywhere that wants to get into writing
of any kind and it was let's just say it
was a bit of a struggle when you're
starting or developing a project to
reach an agreement with the people that
are handling the financials of it and it
certain point where I was very
frustrated I just kept writing
Parabellum Sivas back on Parabellum I
think and it was my little way of saying
yes I will go to war for what I believe
in and we're like yeah sounds good but
it's also I wanted to differentiate you
know we call them chapters so it's not
just John wick John wick to do gentlemen
3 and I wanted to give you know the
Dennis Miller and me wanted to give
everybody a chance to to local learn
something so I think everybody should
learn a little Latin so para bellum now
if you who here doesn't know what para
bellum means it's for war you know and
if you went and learned the whole phrase
see this pack on para bellum you learned
a little something and now you've
associated the word with John week 3 so
it's a bit of branding and marketing as
well hi thank you so much for this
wonderful film I was wondering if you
could just talk a little bit about your
journey from stuntman to second unit
director to directing some of the best
action films and kind of time um brief
over Tommy thanks you know I honestly it
I'm sitting here I was sitting there
last week now I'm sitting here I don't
know it's like anything in your life you
know I don't think it was really a
career choice or anything like that I
grew up in Palmer Massachusetts little
town went to school at USC I want to be
a doctor
writer and then I you know we started
doing martial arts when I was 10
I started doing some judo and some
karate and all the stuff there wasn't
much to do in that little town came to
USC and my roommate was actually in the
film school when I was like you've got
to be kidding me you could major in film
like agar up doing construction and
farming so okay that would seem like a
pretty good major literally got into the
kickboxing and doing some martial art
exhibitions was recognized by you know I
did an exhibition bout in Hollywood and
some stunt coordinators were the
audience and said hey you know would you
be interested in being in a really
little budget film doing some martial
arts I said well okay I'll try it you
know it sounded fun I was only twenty
years old at the time and I made a lot
more money not getting hit did
hit in the head so I thought that was
pretty cool and literally I just I fell
in with the right people I love movies
I've always loved movies since I was you
know a kid with my dad on Sundays
watching all the James Bond's and Steve
McQueen's and Charlie Bronson's I mean I
grew up watching Clint Eastwood and the
Sergio Leone films loved Asian cinema I
mean my friend here Ron we were always a
sneaking down to Santa Monica at a
Laemmle theater before anybody knew this
guy named Jackie Chan watching that and
that kind of just you fall in love with
that and then I don't know it just it's
one of those random things I grew up
loving museums I loved architecture I
loved Renaissance art I love classical
music I love modern music and I don't
know you like to create I like to
sitting here talking with you guys and
when someone offers you a job where you
can do all of it and they'll pay you
I mean you jump at it and you sooner or
later you sit here after you put a lot
of time and going holy [ __ ] it actually
kind of works
I I wish I could say it was all by
choice and design but it was mostly
through luck and passion I guess and I
had I more than anybody the greatest
gift I probably ever had is I had great
mentors I had a stunt coordinator mentor
that was one of the greatest in the
business are a rondelle he was
phenomenal I came out with which house
keys I mean that's film school for the
extreme I don't know anything about that
whole thing but that's amazing I mean
they're geniuses you know one of my
friends was Brandon Lee growing up got a
gate with him and that was a great
experience as well
Janan Isana was my martial arts coach to
this day one most legendary martial
artist of all time and then you know
where I'm at now
my best friend Dave Leitch is just
directed Hobbs and Shah Deadpool to
atomic blonde I just very fortunate to
have the people I have around me that
guide me through all this stuff thank
you sure hey how's it going good so you
know with that comment earlier just
about John wick and Thanos and all how
John wick has kind of crossed over into
like the pop culture and and in that
sense it's like it's kind of a joke or
it's funny that he's crossed over
talking about like the Marvel Universe
but have you considered or maybe what
would even be the logistics of John wick
appearing
in other franchises like maybe fast and
furious Expendables Kingsman
have you considered anything like that I
haven't personally I'm just concerned
about the John wick universe and making
something entertaining for you guys but
I'm sure there are forces out there that
consider stuff like that and do the
what's the key word not a psycho
analytics what that means marketing wise
and legalities I'm sure that's something
somewhere but I'm more concerned with
doing some original content cool I'm
also wondering about John wick versus
Godzilla exactly chance let me tell you
something you can't go wrong with adding
Godzilla to any movie or John wick who
loves god I love next question hi so you
mentioned earlier that every day you
show up does that scared almost to the
point of crapping your pants mm-hmm
I just know halfway there now each of
the three movies when was your first
sort of moment of composure where you
could step back from the chaos and sort
of accept your success success evil word
still waiting I yeah I don't I think
when you're in it you don't really think
so much like that I mean you kind of get
caught up like I i I'm masochistic so I
read like every review of all my films
and also I'm even reading the ones I'm
should be checking right now that's a
little crazy I just like known um I
don't know you're kind of in it you just
want to you get caught up in the passion
I mean if you like to paint you're gonna
paint where somebody says it's socks are
done suck you're gonna paint it's just
what you have to do I like to business
them in I like what I do I'm like with
the people I am I like trying to tell a
story
I like making pretty pictures I don't
know how to stop I don't know what I do
if I didn't if if the financial success
was much less than it currently is and I
couldn't make another movie that was as
big-budget as what this one was and
stuff I make a five million dollar movie
as best I could I'd make it
I'd make a movie with my iPhone the best
they could I would find a way it's just
you know I love the act of working with
my stunt team I like choreography I
would you know still be teaching martial
arts or still be working with stunt team
I'd still be shooting something with
some device that I could you know so I
think that's the important thing and if
you know you're doing things that people
love you'll find an audience I don't
think you go look for the audience first
I don't think you go try to calculate
how to do it and if you do manage to get
something that people like and you do
find a bit of what you term success I
guess I guess you smile you thank the
people that help get you there and you
try again that's about all you can do
thank you so I love John wick so much in
the whole franchise that I got a tattoo
on my arm about two years ago
great it's right before he kills you
stop tears off in the first film is
there a specific reason why almost
everyone has tattoos I think if you if
you look at the tattoos especially in
number three here and you look at who
wears them and what they say there's
enough hints in there between the props
that I've used in the directors abode in
the theatre and the tattoos to kind of
give you a little back story of John
again I'm from the show don't tell
school of showing so if you really want
to know backstory it's there you just
got to look for it but I'm not gonna
have the scene with the two CIA guys
with the folder going John wick he
served in Nam and a third like I think
that's a cheesy way of telling how
badass somebody is if you can't tell
Keanu Reeves badass by now I don't know
so if you want to see backstory and
stuff like that I don't think I need to
have a scene of Keano moping on about
you know when I was this beckon when I
was 12 and so the tattoos are theirs
those are all very planned they're made
from scratch Steve Kelly my makeup and
tattoo guy we put those together with
Russian Latin there's a little history
on John Wick's tattoo so if you look at
it it tells a pretty good story you
should be able to piece together where
he's from where he's going who he is why
he's done what he's done just by his
back
- and I think if you look carefully into
the other tattoos in certain scenes you
you know a little bit of googling I
think you figure things out
yeah I was just curious about like the
phone tellers and all of that - yeah I
just like the symbolism again I I like
visual things and what's a good visual
representation of times is I like the
tats sometimes I think they could be
very creatively fun I think you should
show Chad the tattoo just for the hell
can you see is that is John wick walking
at me or walking away from me you can
come closer
he's got the turtleneck yeah what we
call the tactile neck great that's
awesome
thank you I'm flattered thank you oh we
could ask you a million other questions
but uh I think you have a full day of
press tomorrow and even more press the
day oh do we have do these are a few
more people do you mind going over there
with a microphone it was a little bit
more work to make it you can make the
few steps over so I absolutely love the
movie it was fantastic and my roommate
just got me into the whole John wick
verse and it's amazing
I'm currently I just finished on a TV
show that I worked on and I was there
for two years and I just declined a
renewal for my contract for the next
year so I'm kind of nervous I'm saying
you available I am I am but I just
wanted to ask you do you still get
nervous between jobs how do you tackle
that how do you go out yeah like I said
I you get to a point where you're not
really concerned about what to do next I
don't know I at least me there's a lot
of things I want to do so I'm always I
always kind of point together I never
really get nervous I'm not worried about
like you know I'm technically on
lloyd in three days so like yeah no I
don't I don't really get stressed up I
mean there's so much to do and so many
things to research and like you know
again I say I could watch musicals all
day or I could research Sergey Leone or
I could just go try to learn another
language or take a trip like there's
always research to be done to create an
original story you know if you have
passionate stuff like that whatever your
field is if you're writing directing
whatever I mean you know there's no way
- there's no way better to practice it
than just go do it
so if you're writing write if you're
doing something you don't like go find
something he did - and you better work
at it you know
oh yeah no fear man you can't have any
fear don't fear stop you awesome thank
you see ya
it's so about like the Glass House scene
how many days of shooting was that night
thing I have two nine nine days finished
with the acting scenes and the glass
like could you read put it back in or is
that one take those glass part I mean
the breaking I wanted well there's not
enough glue to put them back together
well no like they bring in another like
they built we bring another ones yes we
had enough for two
again I have a great stunt team the most
we ever do we had to do I think one gag
twice but everything else was pretty
much one takers we rehearse quite a bit
but when you see the long take with the
seven breaks that's all that's the real
deal that's a that's a group of stunt
guys they just know how to do it I'm
also gonna I'm gonna chime in and say I
was on set for one of the glasshouse
days and I watched Keanu get thrown into
one of those glass cases and hit the
ground I mean it must have been seven or
eight times
yeah can was different I'll go along
with you but it was like I couldn't
believe what I was watching in terms of
him constantly getting pushed against
that thing I was you know I was blown
away I am curious though what your
question was forget about standing up do
you want to say it
I mean the stunt team or the cast I got
to repeat the question though so people
online can hear it yeah how do you how
do you choose the guns and and the
modifications
oh god no that is too much the babe also
talked about where we cope with some of
the the intricacies of the gun food
chamber checks and why I choose certain
weapons and how the different
manipulations work in terms of props and
techniques and the ya know it's pretty
funny I just wanted to say that with
what Keanu was able to do in real life
with guns and reloading he's
unbelievable like it's crazy
again it's funny John wick seems so
hyper real and fantastical and all this
stuff like it's a fantasy land that's
the way the real guys really shoot
people you know like it's they don't
mess around you don't wing somebody in
the arm they don't shoot with one hand I
shoot competitively with Taran Butler
I'm actually enjoyed doing three gun
which is four people in Alaska pistol
rifle shotgun I shoot with a Glock a
Benelli and in something called a sig
MPX for a rifle last name things that
can I use in the movie you guys know in
real life you have you do run out of
bullets right okay yeah okay well most
action movies don't address that fact
simple reasons one it slows things down
and two if you see or if you ever get a
chance for those of you shoot or have
trained it's difficult it's not easy
it's sometimes it's slow and awkward and
it takes training you can't just go bang
bang bang bang bang Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing Bing
like you actually gotta have hand-eye
coordination we decided we're gonna let
that go
we're gonna show real time when you see
them adjusting straps on the MPX or
probably the hardest thing that if
anybody with any background in farms
does with the shotgun he's doing
something called quad
he's actually doing it and for anybody
that's actually tried that it's you
actually take four 12-gauge shells out
and hold them between your thumb and
forefinger so you hold it four rounds at
a time you see him slide twice go online
Google three gun championships or
shotgun competitions and you'll see quad
loading and it's incredibly difficult
and cannot trained months and months and
months just for the 5% of the audience
that actually knows what that is that's
just the kind of guy is he also shoot
right-handed and left-handed he'll do
reloads right hand left out he did strap
adjustments left hand right anything
anyone in the military or law
enforcement or competitive shooting
worlds would know and that's just part
of our thing if you know anything about
real jujitsu a real judo you'll see him
doing things in here that for the
regular people or the non martial people
it looks like the same throw over and
over again to any of us that have been
in it it's like holy [ __ ] he's doing
that too holy wow that's impressive and
he's doing both hands both sides just
that's the guy is he wants to go all in
all out on it and the weapons we choose
are usually the ones that we technically
even the 2011 is something we compete
with with a nine-millimeter major which
is you know a new kind of ammunition
fairly in the last decade or so it's
really come up across and then the
Bonelli's and the shotguns and so
everything we use is stuff we actually
practice with in our real lives so
that's kind of how we find it I'm wanted
to do a follow up which by the way it's
again crazy what Keanu does and being
all real but there is a sequence no
spoilers of course where Keanu was
picking out some guns
taking one apart taking parts from one
to the other
where'd that idea come from and how
tricky is it to film something like that
you guys know who Eli Wallach is alright
so you know good too bad the ugly yep
and it's a scene we ripped off from good
the bad the ugly I try to rip off from
the best that's my gig a huge fan of
Sergio Leone and Eli walk we thought
that's fun well if Keanu is so good with
the automatic modern weapons why
wouldn't it be good with period P stuff
and that's a big guy he goes in he's got
one bullet the bullet doesn't fit so
rather than find another bullet build
his own gun
I haven't got called on yet in any
reviews haven't gone but that's for you
gonna call me on it
is like the canted pistol stance based
off of center axis relock or is it just
more of a stylish
no it's generally like that's where we
found it we trained with everything from
le SWAT to some of the Navy SEALs the
Special Forces JSOC to Russian Spetsnaz
to all this other stuff and then we kind
of create our own obviously there's no
such thing as gun foo you don't do
Aikido and Aiki jujitsu and judo and
then shoot yourself and the guy okay so
that's a creative Liberty we took but
it's based on that but then it's Keano
doing his own thing but then when this
is like the character's motivation to
use center access versus you know
isosceles or Weaver uh close-quarter in
motion it's always about motion motion
motion when you don't know the
environment it's very easy to stand and
shoot a target it's a lot differently
moving through crowds and you don't know
who's on your side like in real life the
bad guys aren't wearing a big sound this
is bad guy so you got to be ready to
move it depends like kannas he and I are
both left-handed but we both right
handed and we're somewhat ambidextrous
for their reloads
so for Keanu we strain on both sides
when he goes like that you can easily
shift the gun to either hand
on that note I'm gonna force you get a
little geeky there I wasn't no no
actually I look I love that [ __ ] that's
great but I want the studio well you
need to what we call leave so I'm just
gonna say that I want it and I mean this
sincerely a huge thank you to Lionsgate
for letting us screen the movie early a
huge thank you to IMAX for being such an
awesome partner and for providing such
an incredible format for the movie going
experience again John wick three will be
in IMAX theaters this Friday for one
week and the format's incredible and I
can't recommend it enough
Chad congratulations on the movie in
your 95% score on Rotten Tomatoes
thank you wish you nothing but the best
thank you so much for doing the QA Thank
You Stephen thank you guys
thank you thank you everyone